awesome care orthopedics and spine the
sponsors of this next segment is
introducing us to a new doctor here to
care for our community with his medical
experience from across the globe check
it out
now it's time to get to know you you are
new to optim care orthopedic and spine
so tell us about yourselves
uh so i grew up in miami florida i was
an engineer before i went into medicine
i did my orthopedic residency in utah
and two fellowships in earthquake trauma
and orthopedic spine at harborview
medical center in seattle i take care of
badly injured patients on the trauma
side of things at university medical
center and then also take care of
patients with spine problems that ranges
from
traumatic spine injury to degenerative
disease and scoliosis and
disc herniations and things like that
okay and you're also involved and i want
to get this right the orthopedic
residency program at the kirk krikorian
school of medicine okay
more about that
yeah so we have a residency training
program
uh we train rent for residents a year i
take medical students i take them for
five years and turn them into orthopedic
surgeons
so i train residents in both treatment
of fractures and and treatment of spine
pathology
and i also understand that you have
you've done a lot of charitable work as
well so
good luck to know you on that side of
things uh i've been involved with uh
global health type work since i was in
undergrad uh back in the early 2000's
worked with engineers at borders in
africa in rwanda and cameroon
uh and then throughout medical training
worked in in peru and
haiti dominican republic and and
um south africa down in cape town
i worked at the
big trauma center there and then i spent
a year doing research in global health
and worked in in ghana
and kind of helped uh surgeons from
africa
in their academic
purposes so
research training helped facilitate some
courses and i've written a couple of
papers with uh for public health uh with
public health health data for
orthopedics and injury in the developing
world
i um and then also helps uh set up
courses for uh training on specific
matters such a diverse experience within
the medical world outside the medical
world um so now you're bringing all of
that to southern nevada what do you
bring to the table here and how excited
are you to help our community i i think
i bring a um so i bring a broad
perspective so trained in both trauma
and spine
and then i you know i've spent time in
many parts of the world and i
bring that kind of international
perspective you know las vegas is a lot
like south florida and that it's a very
diverse place with the people from all
over the world melting pot and
we see pathology here in in southern
nevada that's that is
you know akin to some of the things we
see
in in a place like cape town for example
injuries that have been neglected or
patients that haven't been able to get
in to see the right person and uh um so
i think i bring a broad perspective and
open mind to a lot of that so
thank you optimum care orthopedics and
spine for sponsoring that segment
they're located on west oaky boulevard
for more information just call
702-724-8877